mes 13 conseils avant une grosse soirée
dor faut toujours arriver en pleine
forme à une grande compétition mange un
truc qui tient bien au corps et qui se
digère facilement avant de partir
prépare ton lit et surtout pose une
grosse bouteille d'eau sur ta table de
chevet prévois de quoi manger pour le
lendemain des trucs légers sans sauce
qui se digère bien prévois des pastilles
à la menthe aussi parce que tu vas puer
du mec le mieux c'est de pas trop boire
évidemment mais si tu bois alterne un
verre d'alcool un verre de soft
idéalement un verre d'eau bois pas trop
vite sinon tu vas perdre le contrôle et
tu vas faire un blackout prévois un
moyen de rentrer chez toi la voiture
c'est non le lendemain truc important
mange mais par petite quantité et
surtout pas trop gras ça ferait trop
bosser ton foie et il a déjà du boulot
parce que c'est lui qui est chargé
d'éliminer l'alcool oublie le doliprane
pour les mêmes raisons bois plein plein
d'eau mais pas d'alcool ton foir reste
pas à rien faire sur ton canape prends
une petite douche et va marcher même un
tout petit peu brosse-toi les dents et
prends la petite pastille à la mene que
tu as mis de côté allez bonne soirée